[Musique]
ça fait plus de cent ans les ancêtres de
martin prince se sont installés en
saskatchewan
les acadiens déportés qui ont fini par
trouver refuge dans les champs des
prairies si on a beau être attaché aux
traditions on n'hésite pas à innover
il ya deux ans et demi on a décidé de
faire poser des panneaux solaires ici
pour erreur minimiser notre limite est
un peu notre impact sur l'environnement
vous avez des panneaux solaires en même
temps vous me dites que vous êtes contre
la taxe sur le carbone c'est pas une
contradiction pour vous non ce n'est pas
parce que ça fait des années et des
années qu'on essaie de minimiser notre
impact sur l'environnement
on veut continuer à le faire mais quand
on impose une taxe carbone ça me limite
les moyens de pouvoir justement
m'améliorer car à la ferme martin prince
a besoin de carburant au quotidien
mouvoir ses gros engins pour faire venir
les semences ou les engrais qui arrivent
de loin ou encore pour sécher grain
comme il le fait en ce moment avec du
propane
on m'oblige de payer mais n'a pour
pouvoir faire le travail qui est
essentiel que vous ne voudriez pas
manger du pain quand tu avais de la
farine de blé qui n'a pas été ça chez
vous ça ferait une colle ottawa a quand
même mis en place certaines exemptions
pour les agriculteurs disent elles
utilisées dans les moissonneuses et les
tracteurs pas taxer les beaucoup
d'autres opérations de son il n'y a pas
de remise du fédéral alors qu'il y en a
une pour les consommateurs individuels
je dois faire transporter tout mais
toute ma production au port de mer que
ce soit vancouver femmes berbères au
prince hubert ou aux états unis qui ce
qu'ils payent les taxes carbone assure
le transport par la suite c'est nous
cette année ça va être entre neuf et
onze mille dollars que je veux payer une
taxe carbone
[Musique]
c'est des fois j'en pense plus à l'est
de la saskatchewan laurent denis un
autre fermier francophone croit lui
aussi que la taxe sur le carbone rate sa
cible avec les agriculteurs
le changement du climat c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on doit ignorer ça
existe mais à nous charger plus d'argent
mais temps une taxe sur le carburant ne
changera pas mes habitudes
au contraire dit il en payant des taxes
j'ai moins d'argent pour prendre
davantage d'après moi les nouvelles
technologies
même si plusieurs experts croient qu'ils
firmi ont besoin d'incitatifs financiers
pour devenir plus écologiques en
saskatchewan bien les agriculteurs
souligne qu'ils ont déjà amélioré leurs
pratiques dans les dernières années
je tiens le climat au coeur mon
entreprise au départ ma vie en dépend
simplement c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça surtout distille aidez nous à devenir
plus vert où les six nous gérer ça tout
seul ici leur ans tentait radio-canada à
delmas saskatchewan
il
[Musique]